this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's taking a look at the
warhammer 40k shooter
necromunda hired gun finally we have a
bolter and as originally described
in in the original rule set these were
meant to be caseless
rocket projectiles which calls to mind
the gyrojet system which is bonkers
if there are any of the games guns and
mechanics that you want to see jonathan
break down let us know in the comment
section below
make sure to subscribe if you want to
see more videos like this and if you'd
like to help out the royal armies museum
and continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
all right i'm going to pause there
because a few things
i certainly appreciate the aesthetic
from a firearm perspective it's a bit
odd i think
they definitely don't look like real
world guns which i think is a plus they
shouldn't
we've got the picatinny rails if you
don't if you don't know those are the
ridged strips originally a strip on top
of the receiver for an optical sight and
then that got
longer and then they got added at one
point all over the weapon for adding on
lights lasers bottle openers so you can
literally attach anything to anything
it's
like a sort of lego system for guns
there's no reason to think that will
go away anytime soon off top of my head
i'd say that system is probably going to
be around
in one form or another for at least 50
years but we've already seen it start to
be
supplanted by other accessory systems
point being
i can't see it lasting a millennia plus
into our future
to appear on these weapons then the the
sights themselves so um
i like the idea of what they did with
the iron sights they just they they work
like einstein sort of but they're hyper
stylized you know you've got a rear
sight made of two separate portions it
looks really gnarly and very metal but
it's not
very practical and if we increasingly
don't have iron sights on our firearms
now we're certainly not going to have
them in the in the far
future where there is only war or
whatever the phrase is
grim dark future of course
i think a magnum revolver kind of
substitute was inevitable for a game
like this
and here it is it almost looks looks a
bit like a chiappa rhino
or maybe even a nerf maverick or
something some big
chunky or maybe the revolver from gears
of war the hammer looks like it's
something designed
for some sort of masochist if that is a
hammer if that even [ __ ] i don't know
but excessively textured i think that
would that would not be very comfortable
and we have a really weird set of sights
on this thing
they look like they're lifted from a
sort of present day combat rifle of some
sort so folding backup sites
that you would have if your optical
sight breaks
or you need to take it off for some
reason you can flip up
the backup size and they have two
different
apertures so we've got like a notch
which weirdly enough looks to be
replicated on the top of the gun itself
i don't know how that works
and then it looks like you can flip that
to a little peep site
we've got some glowing night sight iron
sights
that clip onto the rail making the bulky
revolver even bulkier
several features added here we've got a
suppressor on there why not
it's essentially a space revolver we
don't have to worry about the cylinder
gap
so why not suppress it although i'd
expect firearms this far in the future
to incorporate sound suppression in
their design and we also see how
it's being reloaded here so it's a
conventional cylinder design
but rather than loading the rounds into
the cylinder
either singly or with a speed loader we
see the whole cylinder get taken out
thrown away and another one put on the
crane
i don't know why you would need to empty
the the cylinder you've taken off
take it off the gun i mean if you don't
you know if we're being realistic and
you don't want to just drop it and lose
it just put it in a pouch somewhere or a
pocket somewhere
with the empty still in it and reload it
when you're not about to be murdered by
somebody
it's a slightly illogical process but
i'm guessing it's there to protract the
loading of what is clearly quite a
powerful
weapon to even out balance
this is another fairly conventional 20th
century looking gun to my eyes
in fact although the the rifle's called
the striker this is reminiscent of
something like a striker shotgun now i
said this about gears of war years ago
and i'm going to say it about this
why on earth would we still have pump
action shotguns the the reason for a
manually operated shotgun is so you can
reliably fire a wide variety of
different ammunition that may not cycle
your
self-loading shotgun but of course we
know why it's a pump shotgun
it's because it's cool it's a it's
definitely rule of cool applies
not only have you got massive drum
magazines including a massive
double drum magazine which actually
makes the whole weapon look pretty
dubious if you ask me
with a great big um muzzle device on the
end of it as well
but maybe that's quite fitting for what
we're going for i don't know
yeah pump pumping away on this massive
40 round i think i mean i don't think
you'd physically fit 40 rounds of 12
gauge in there but
i don't know what ammunition this is
supposed to be firing
okay right i've finally reached the
point where the rule of cool
actually applies to me because i really
like that 40k
up double barrel shotgun to uh too much
of a fan of the super shotgun from doom
2
but um it's like that with bells on
i like the the external hammers complete
nonsense of course
you would not need external hammers on
any weapon in the future
but it gives it that sort of piratical
vibe
again we see those sort of stock iron
sights so i gather they've done the
classic fps thing and
created a created a rail system that
fits across the board so your your all
of your firearms can be upgraded
along similar paths bit of a shame i
think you unique upgrades would be
better i like the the sort of uh the
ornate nature of the things we've got
the external hammers there's
the curve of the grip they've actually
modeled
complete external locks you know it's
like an old-school side-by-side
shotgun that sort of harks back to
percussion and flintlock and all of that
i can't help liking it nice bit of
design
i was literally off camera joking about
about skulls
being on or part of or even a whole
weapon in this game
and um sure enough this gun has little
skull
iron sights on it which i can only um
give a very quiet round of applause to
because that's
very warhammer and very metal i i enjoy
it very much and it completely negates
all of my complaints about iron sights
the weapon itself with its
unpronounceable name which
is a mystery to me perhaps those of you
who know warhammer know why it's called
the panther it has the sort of general
aesthetics of a bolter
reading between the lines if something's
called an auto gun
and although it looks a bit like a
bolter it's chucking out brass cases
this is a holdover of
present day technology so standard
brass case self-contained metallic
ammunition
i don't know but that's what i'm seeing
so it's almost like the halo franchise
where
500 years in the future we're still
using 762 nato
similar applies here what i don't think
we would have is brass cased
ammunition but what do i know
finally we have a bolter or a bolt gun
and as originally described i gather
in in the original rule set these were
meant to be caseless
rocket projectiles which calls to mind
and the comparison has been made
the gyrojet system which is bonkers
it fires miniature rockets and the
rocket propellant
burns within there and jets these four
little
jets out the base at an angle
causing rotation so you get rotational
stability
not from rifling in the weapon but from
the rotation
of the miniature rocket that you're
firing and when people read about
bolters
i think that's is how they're supposed
to work but
in depictions of them they are shown
chucking out massive cartridge cases
with big old rims on them
which which is kind of at odds with the
idea of a caseless or in this case
rocket projectile system like the gyro
jet so an intriguing system
and it sort of acts as this real world
parallel for the bolters but as i say
not really because the only way these
are rocket projectiles is if they are
two stage
so there's some sort of an expelling
charge in the cartridge case
chucks the projectile out clear of the
weapon
and then a rocket motor kicks in now in
this game
there's no vapor trail there's no sudden
acceleration of the projectile there's
no real delay between
pulling the trigger and your target
moving that a rocket projectile would
induce like the gyrojet if you watch
videos of that
so i don't see any evidence of that what
this is is essentially
a handheld cased ammunition grenade
launcher so it's
slow rate of fire chugging away when the
projectiles hit something there's a
payload in there they're big they're
chunky they explode they do damage
but you've still got these great big not
only cases but brass cases just like the
auto guns
and they are engraved elaborately which
i think is a really nice touch
and they just kind of chunkle out of the
side of the of the gun
they're not really thrown clear which
again is somewhat uh similar to how a
automatic grenade launcher might work
that makes sense for like for someone
like a space marine
giant robust armored character that can
carry this basically carry
a modern day belt fed grenade launcher
around with them
except they're not belt fed they've
always got these big curved magazines
and there's no way you're fitting all
those gigantic rounds
in that magazine so we definitely have
we're cheating some physics there
again they fit the aesthetic they fit
the feel they look fun to use
the explosive effects on the target are
pretty graphic so i applaud them on that
level
i'm still confused as to how bolters are
supposed to work in the 40k universe
though
we're outside my comfort zone now um in
terms of expertise
so i'm aware of the the last guns from
the franchise
this is a plasma weapon though so this
is a
blue ball of energy as you can see flies
towards the enemy
and we've got what looks like a charge
up mechanism
obviously something you can't do with
conventional firearms
in any way as a franchise 40k has always
embraced different different
technologies sort of have your cake and
eat it too so you conventional firearms
rocket bullet firearms laser guns plasma
guns and probably more things that i
don't even know about
i suppose one thing to say about these
this sort of sci-fi energy weapon is
that they tend to give away your
position
so there's nearly always some big
glowing thing on them and in this case
it's like half
the big old chunk of the receiver is
like barely contained blue energy
and that's a hard thing to to hide we've
spent about a century trying to conceal
muzzle flash
in one way or another and we're prepared
to abandon that for something that glows
bright blue
in broad daylight never mind in the dark
then again if it's got that much
destructive potential
maybe you don't care that the enemy
knows where you are
another bolter this time a pistol it
certainly makes some sense
in an fps because you you get some of
the advantage of a bolter
as a secondary if you want your first
your private weapon to be something else
the site on this one that we're seeing
here is really interesting i've spoken
before about
holographic sites and i don't mean glass
and metal optical sites that use
holographics
to display the reticle i mean suspended
in mid-air
holographic reticles because that has to
be where we're going
it's probably a way off but that's
that's kind of where i see the
technology going and the thing we've got
here is
maybe what the next step with that would
be so we still have a frame
quite a robust looking metal frame and
it's called gnarly and 40k like
and then it's projecting from either
side this reticle so you get a pretty
good field of view because that's the
thing with optical sights is
as you know from gaming they they
constrain your field of view you've got
less
peripheral vision less vision other than
what you're in
who knows where it will go i am
spitballing here in a rather sci-fi way
but it's nice to see something that is
going in that direction and isn't just a
conventional iron sight with
some gnarly bits on it or a conventional
optical site that just looks a bit
different those those aren't really
interesting to me
this is interesting and i think fits the
the world quite well
so an uh an interesting category weapon
i hadn't heard of called a stubbor
which just calls to mind hurting your
toe on furniture it's a bit more capable
than that and this is a heavy stubborn
so this almost seems like
between a an auto gun and a bolt gun
i don't really understand the difference
but it's clearly firing conventional
ammunition of some sort
big heavy slow rate of fire and held
almost like a
this thing looks like a sort of mini gun
without the spinning barrels with it
with a top mounted
pistol grip still got an iron front
sight god knows how you're supposed to
use that when you're holding it under
under hand and a sort of big motorbike
grip on the side that's all very 40k
looks good looks fun
we've got here the big brother of the
chunky revolver we saw earlier now we
tend to think of revolvers as being
handguns
but of course they weren't always there
were revolving rifles revolving carbines
that
went in parallel and we have we have
several of those in the in the
collection none of them are as massive
and destructive as this though this is
really like a
sort of two-handed magnum in concept and
i like it quite a lot it's good
i'm struck by the fact that even more so
than the other revolver it seems to have
like a stylized
hammer on the back of it that doesn't do
anything so i don't know if that's
meant to be like a stylistic throwback
to the revolvers of
the ancient times or something or is
just supposed to fill a bit of space on
the back of the design
but it is quite old it's old technology
in various ways hey
the universe seems to embrace the old
and and the
sci-fi quite a lot
okay well that looks like a lot of fun
we've got essentially
a milk or mgl or m32 or whatever you
want to call it
futuristic take on another present-day
weapon that
i'm sure you're familiar with 40
millimeter revolving drum
the revolving grenade launcher and uh
works very similarly
this has got an eight round sort of
magazine speed loader cylinder thing
the logistics of carrying around
multiples of those is we won't worry
about that this is fantasy after all
sci-fi fantasy
the way that i mean the explosions are
very hollywood fireball
really nicely done so and the sound
effect is a really nice take on that
classic grenade launcher thump sound
[Music]
if you'd like to support the work that
we do here at the royal armouries we
have
links in the description as to how you
can help us do come and visit one of our
sites if you're able to
and if you're not just watch us again
next time thanks a lot guys
[Music]
you